Jim Carrey has raised some eyebrows with
his response to one question during a
Sonic the Hedgehog interview heat
magazine's Charlotte long asked him
about his bucket list and his answer has
some offended and in the film Sonic has
a bucket list and I was wondering after
all you've done in your career and in
your life is there anything still left
on your bucket list just you it's all
done now just own it right okay so
what's that okay so so yeah so here well
let's play sangita's club because
Sangeeta did the same interview with Jim
Carrey and yes the theme of the movie is
bucket list and Sangeeta asked him the
same question and this was Jim's answer
to Sangeeta movie Kahn has a metaphor of
Sonic trying to live everything off the
bucket list yeah on your bucket list my
bucket list
G I would like to explode into a ball of
light that's one thing you know until
then I just I just want to be I just
want to be a tree full of mangoes I like
that mangoes were sweet and they're the
gift of the gods to me it says the
universe is abundant it's always trying
to give you gifts you know okay so
getting a straight answer to Jim Carrey
is almost impossible right that's the
first thing and this is somebody who sat
in that chair answered that same
question a hundred times that day and as
you can see from his answers to Sangeeta
what's on your bucket list exploding
into a ball of light and then becoming a
tree filled with mangoes and then when
the other lady asked him you know what's
on your bucket list and he said you and
then he says it's all over now I didn't
take that as like you sexually I took
that when I first heard this as though
this moment between us exactly what was
on my bucket list she doesn't say what's
left to do any but she just says what's
on your bucket list yeah this is you and
then it says it's done and he says it's
done now which is applying that in this
moment together this interview some
people like
Thompson says everyone is offended these
days mas says he's a comedian that's a
joke cwg says that is so rude he's a
player can this list oh gosh that Lisa
says it meant meeting her yeah so people
are jumping all over this clip but
literally yeah she doesn't see some
simply says she doesn't say what's left
to do any buckless yeah and then he's
just you and then he says it's done now
that's who's saying just talking about
this interview yeah it's like we're
jumping all over we're not something
guys this is just somebody who's he
should have said this interview yes he
should have fries sort of him yes but
you know he's just it's the same
question over and over and over again
and he just refuses to give a straight
answer because it would be very easy if
Jim Carrey said I want to go to Nepal
and then you had 50 interviews where
everybody asked him but his bucket list
and he said I want to go to Nepal but
that's not Jim Carrey he tries to give
everybody something unique to take away
that's different from the person that
was in the room before he's a pro and
he's done these things a million times
but no he was not talking about sex it
was talking about this moment and then
they said and it's over now own it you
know like that kind of thing right like
so I was this moment was on Jim Carrey's
bucket list lisa says people love
twisting stuff into drama
yeah so this was nothing